&gt;&gt; That, well that's interesting, I mean, like with games there's a minimum
requirements, you know, you must have this DirectX 11, or dadadadada. so, do
you have like minimum requirements or are there sort of tiers of support or how
does that work?
&gt;&gt; We have a, minimum set of requirements for your system and for graphics card,
but we also have a very thorough certification process because. Even if a card
says that, you know, it runs DX11, it has all these effects, there can be
problems with a card of a driver. So we actually have to go through card driver
combinations, certifying each one, run through a whole list of effects, make
sure they can do each one well and efficiently. Because depending on the
customer, some customers may want the visual accuracy and don't care as much
about the performance. Some want the performance and don't care as much about
the visual accuracy. So depending on what it is we're striving for. If we have
an effect that looks really good but is slow, that will work for some customers
but not all customers.
&gt;&gt; [CROSSTALK]
There are also the frame rate issues that you see, particularly in games. Where
a game has to run at 30 hertz or 60 hertz. And, again, they will cut some
corners in order to, to be able to do that. We don't have those strict
requirements, in CAD. Although there are times when someone has a model. They
need to orbit it, they need to pan around. So, we do need to get good frame
rate out of that. And we'll actually play some of those same tricks, where
we'll slightly degrade the visuals in order to be able to, to want, to see the
model moving, and then when you stop, we, we cut off the degradation and bring
back the original model.